Hey guys, my name is Sean Hayes, I know we haven't repeated our names in a while, but my name is Sean Hayes. Yeah, this is Jason Baby, just to be clear, I gotta get dressed, we're about to start, right? Yeah, yeah, yeah. In case you don't know what the show's like, one of us brings down a kiss, the other doesn't know about it. It's a surprise.
I don't know what we got. And I'm Will Arnett. Is it my turn yet? Sorry. And welcome to SmartLess. Do you want to see a great photo I got? Do you like photos? Oh yeah, that was today's golf outfit.
Yeah, I went with the light pants today because it's warm out here in Los Angeles. Look at Jason, Jason's wife Amanda sent this dancing in the morning. Is that you, Jason? Well, I was happy about my outfit, just looked great, you know, I was happy. Those particular pants you've worn them before, and I gotta say they're not my favorite. Oh, they're not. Is there a compliment on the end of it, because they're white? You look great, which is, first of all, you don't look bad in them, I said they're not
my favorite. Right. No, I know. That front piece. It kind of looks like a... That's a penis. That's what we call it, the front is. The front piece.
You mean the... It's kind of like a fold over, it almost looks like a formal slack. Right. Yeah, it is. I think it is a bit of a trouser that they made there. Yeah. Sorry. Listener, just going over latest golf wear.
Hang on. I'm trying to put this into... Golf fashion. Sean, just so that Sean can feel... I came on a little late today. You did come on late. What's going on? You're still in the city.
I'm still in the city. I had to change... Don't you have to change clothes like two, three times a day because the humidity is just... You can walk outside. I'm just drenched in sweat. Yeah. What are you doing outside?
Just stay inside. You have a beautiful apartment. He's walking around, man. Yeah. No, I tried to because it's air conditioning in here. Is it real humid back east right now? Yes. It's unbelievable.
It's unbelievably humid right now. Yeah. It's humid out here, so it must be terrible out there because it travels. So then Sean, so you and Scotty, you just pop out of the apartment and you just start walking around. Do you have some favorite places you'd like to go to? Well, we do. I mean, there's one restaurant.
Do you bring misters? Do you guys bring misters? No, we bring misters. Just to clear. No, there's one French restaurant we like on the east side. Oh, this is what I did for the first time in my entire life. I walked through Central Park. What?
First time ever? What are you talking about first time ever? Oh, I get real. I mean, I've walked like, you know, just from, you know, like to that restaurant that I can't remember. Tavern on the Green? Yeah. I walked there once, but I never walked from like upper west side all the way through it
all the way down. It's kind of scary because they have, in the center, they have all those paths that go in like 10,000 different directions. Oh, granddad. But then, yeah. Did you see the skating rink over there, too? I did. Yeah.
Yeah, the roller skating rink. It was a roller skating rink. No, in the summertime. Ma, you can't believe how big it is. Mom, huh? Well, they had people walking everywhere and people just seemingly going, they were busy. It was wild. Just walls and walls of buildings.
We used to, when I, back when I was, when I was first living in New York, 45 years ago, and I was very broke, we used to just walk through the park because we had nothing else to do. And it was free. And we'd just have a head full of rope and we'd just walk around with shades on, you know, gig-less. That's weed, listener. Weird.
Head full of, I'd never heard of that before. Head full of rope. Yeah. And we'd just walk around and sit on the grass and, I don't know, maybe smoke some butts and then like, just walk over a different part. Yeah. Because it was free. We had nothing to do and we were, you know, we were broke, broke, broke.
But it was great. I love such a walk. But you know, my, do you guys go to a chiropractor because all you do is walk, right? In New York? Am I back as fucking killing me? What kind of shoes, what kind of shoes you got right now? By the way, this is an opportunity for you to get some new shoes. Yeah.
Are you ready? Speak smartly here. I like that. What do you want? What do you like? I forget what they're called. We all have them. They're called the on shoes.
Those. You might need like leg braces or something. If you're blowing your back out, just walking. How would you feel about a wagon? And then Scottie pulls it. Would you sit in a wagon? I'm not above it. I'm not above it.
You've seen the dogs with the blown out backs. Yeah. Right. With the little, little carts. I would walk around. What about a Segway? Yeah. What about a Segway?
Once you get electric bikes and park them in your apartment. Yeah. Yeah. I think we have to do bikes. I think it'd be fun. Get by, but you're coming out here tomorrow. Yes. And hopefully.
Obviously you don't like, we'll come in. You don't have to do anything. We'll just go where you want. You're going for lunch at our friend. You're going for lunch at our friend's house. Yeah. And then you're going to look around. Yeah.
And then we have a dinner tomorrow night. Perfect. And then we leave first thing in the morning. Chappy's here. Chappy's on his way here. I can't wait. He's in, Bob is here. And my sister is here right now with my brother in law, Ed.
It's a houseful. Yeah. Yeah. Except for. It's going to be a lot of fun. Hey Jason, have fun. Yeah. You got everybody there except me, I guess.
Yeah. I know you should come out because we've got other plants. Okay. All right. We're doing other things. Okay. Yeah. You guys are going to have a different vacay, which I don't, I don't know.
Finish the sentence. I just don't know why you don't come out to where we are. All your friends are out here is what I'm saying. You know, it's not up to me. I'm not living in a dictatorship. This is a democratic house and there's a lot of complications to our trips. Maybe that's your problem. As you know.
That's by the way, that's the thing is you think is a democracy and you do live in a dictatorship. The problem is you're not the dictator. Yeah. That's so funny. It's true. Speaking of dictator, terrible segue because it does not apply to this person at all. But I will say this is so many.
I'm really excited. I'm excited because Sean, I can't wait to see how excited you are because this is going to hit you right in a sweet spot. Must be an athlete. Right in a sweet spot for you. And also for me, he's been in a lot of films that I just absolutely love. I remember his first film. I'm not going to say the title yet.
I think it was his first film, maybe a second film, but the first film that really had a lot of sort of wide acclaim with a very famous director as well. And I remember thinking like this guy, he just has, I don't know, I can't not watch him when he's on screen. He's got that thing. You know, there are certain performers who have that. That thing where you're just like you're glued to and you're with him on everything he says, no matter the role.
This is this guy. He's, and he's won Emmys and he's won Golden Globes and he's been a globe trotter in that he's gone around the globe on his motorcycle. He's an incredible actor. He is Obi-Wan Kenobi. He's an incredible actor. Watch! I got it right on the motorcycle.
How's it going? Why is Ewan McGregor in Sean's wheelhouse? What are you talking about? Sean is the most massive Star Wars fan of all time. Are you joking me? Oh, right, right, right. I was thinking song and dance. What did you think?
Oh, I see you. Wait, Ewan. Oh my God, this is so cool to meet you. How are you doing? I'm so nervous. I don't know why I'm so nervous. Why? Don't be nervous.
Sean does that to everybody. It's weird. You have nothing to be nervous about. We are absolute fools and there's nothing to this show. It's idiocy. Trust me. It's titled appropriate. You're immediately the smartest guy in the room.
Here comes Scotty. Don't worry about it. Scotty's going to lose it. Do you know who the guest is? Just let him look and don't tell him. Look at that. Oh my God. That's my husband.
Ewan McGregor, welcome and welcome. This is so cool. What an honor to have you here on the show. It's such a great pleasure for me to be on. I was just an enormous fan of yours, buddy. Do you know Train Spotting is one of my favorite movies of all time. What has he done that has been bad? Ewan, you answer that.
Hang on. I was going to start with this. That film I'm talking about Ewan is Shallow Grave, of course. Can you talk to us a little bit of how that came together and what that experience was like and where met you in your life at that time? That film? Yeah.
It was the first film I ever made. You were right. Is this good? Yes. Brilliant. You were right. It was the first film I ever made. I did a drama school and I did a six-month shoot
on a Dennis Potter series called Lipstick on Your Collar. So I got out of drama school and straight in front of a camera for six months, which was amazing like training, if you like, in that respect. And then I did a play and then I did a period drama called The Red and the Black. And then I went for an audition for this film called Shallow Grave. So I'd done a couple of things on television and I guess...
Did you know Danny Boyle before that? No. I didn't know any of them. And they were really very much like a three-person team. Danny, the director, of course, and then Andrew McDonald was the producer and John Hodge, the writer. And the three of them were very much like a creative team,
like really truly they were. And was Trainspotting the same team? That was them, yeah. And that's when I met them the first time and I was just lucky to get... I was so hungry and so fucking like... Let me add it, you know, I felt like I'd been ready for a long time, you know?
Yeah, yeah, yeah. And then I got on the stage, you know, we shot it so quickly we built that apartment in Shallow Grave in a factory in Glasgow, you know? And it was all... It was so Brian Tafano shot it, who went on to shoot Trainspotting and Lifeless Ordinary. And he's a brilliant cinematographer.
I auditioned for a Lifeless Ordinary. Did you really? Oh, did you? Yeah, and for Danny Boyle, I was so nervous. I had just moved to Los Angeles and in the scene, he's supposed to throw keys at me, so I brought keys to act like they were just thrown at me. And he threw me his set of keys,
so then I had two set of keys in the scene. Did you know that he was going to do it? No, he might have heard it. No, I didn't. Wow, that's risky. He was going to do it. So, Dan, how was the shoot? Sean, how was the shoot?
I didn't get it. So, I'll bet you were great in the audition, but I would imagine that those guys that you also got the job also because it seems like you kind of fit in with their kind of fabric. They just seem like good dudes like you and did that kind of bring about Trainspotting as well?
I mean, aside from your talent. Yeah, yeah, it was interesting because it was all of our first movies. Danny had been a director in the theatre for years and I think that's why he's so very good. I didn't know that. And this was his first movie and Andrew's first movie and John was a doctor who wrote this brilliant script
about these people. I guess he trained in Edinburgh, so he knew about, like, Edinburgh life and living in that city. And, yeah, it was just a most amazing experience, but I felt like it was like the other things I'd done. You know, I did that period drama and I'd done that lipstick and your collar was set in the 50s
and it was all single-camera work anyway. So, I felt much the same until I saw it and I saw what they'd been doing, you know, visually and what Brian took the shots that Danny and Brian dreamt up. Wow. It sort of felt like... It really felt like we'd sort of made a mark on British cinema. That's how it felt when it came out.
Yes, you did. And then we took it to... It was my first adult trip to America. We came to Sundance with it. And I'd been in the States when I was nine with my parents, which was ridiculous. Nobody comes to America for holidays. Like, it's too big of a deal, you know?
But when I was nine, we came over. It was my first time back as a sort of grown-up. And I went to Sundance with Shallow Grave and they gave me the script there for train spotting. Oh, my God, how cool. And they always said... We're not offering you this and it's not an offer and we just want to know what you think of it.
And so, I read that on the plane. I was like, fucking hell. I mean, it's the role of a lifetime, isn't it? It's like one of the great leading roles. But John... I think I'm right. John didn't think I was right for it because in the novel, in Irvine Welsh's novel, Ewan Bremner, who played Spud,
had played wrents in the stage version before we made the movie. Oh, it was a play, train spotting was a play? It was a novel first and then they made a play of it and Ewan Bremner was in the play as wrent. And in fact, he's much better casting in terms of the wrenton that's written in the novel. He's much more Ewan Bremner-esque than me-esque. So, I think John wasn't quite convinced
and I just had to do it. So, I went away and I just lost loads of weight. I didn't eat and... Yeah. When you say you went away, where'd you go? Like a hole in the ground? Where did you go? Where do you got to go to lose weight? Well, I just did it.
They still hadn't offered it to me. They still hadn't said that it was my role, but I just thought, fuck it, I'm going to make them know that it's my role. So, I went away and I just saw them now and again, but we'd made that movie together and Andrew had an office in Soho in London that I would drop into now and again.
So, I just didn't see them for a wee while. I just shed loads of weight because I was young and it was easier to do then, you know? Yeah, yeah. And I was a big... I was a nasty drinker back in the day and I remember I just started drinking white wine and clear stuff, you know, instead of...
The alcoholic sort of dieting, you know? I just drink the clear ones, you know? And it seemed to work, actually, to a degree. Anyway, I lost all the weight and then I went back in to see them and I think they were like, OK, because I looked more right then. I was more sort of emaciated and stuff.
But, I mean, it was the most amazing experience making that film, too. By the way, that film had just took the world by... I was going to say, surprise, but it just took it by storm, really. I feel like that movie kind of shifted the way people made movies for a while there, the way people made movies,
because it was very edgy and obviously it was very raw and had a lot of... But it wasn't just for the sake of it. There was kind of a point to all of it and there was something deeper happening. It was very cool. Sean, by the way, I can see the wheel is turning. You're just hoping, like, God,
train spotting the musical. If there's any way that Ewan could find a way to get you involved with that. Five, six, seven, eight, hero in here and then it's a more hero in there. If Danny decides to do it, you go in and this time, maybe you wouldn't bring your own keys.
Keys. Wait, Ewan, speaking of that, when you guys did the drugs in the movie, it was like both incredibly... Incredible to watch this as actors, but just like, it looks so real. I can't imagine... Did Danny ever talk you through
what the experience was for a hard crowd? I don't even... I want to ask you if you actually did it to get into character. But like, how did you get there? Because it did look so real. By saying, I don't want to ask you, by the way, I know it's a soft ask.
Totally just an ask, isn't it? Yes, an ask. It really is. I'm not going to ask you. I'm just going to put you in a difficult position, but go ahead, Ewan. No, it's quite an interesting point because I didn't do heroin.
I've never done heroin, but I did think about it and I thought, I don't want to do heroin's addicts to disservice by getting it wrong. Right. So I did think, I did cross my mind,
and I did say to Danny... You don't want to disrespect the heroin. No, no, I was just researching. I was just trying to disrespect the addicts. What do you mean? Why do I have a lighter under this spoon? I start shooting in three weeks. Yes!
So I brought it up and I said, look, do you think we should do it? And I got... I really thought about it because I thought, well, John, our writer, he's a doctor. Like, he could do it to us properly, you know, so that we don't die and stuff.
I could probably administer the... Oh, my God. Yeah, right, so that we were safe-ish. And... But it just became apparent that that was... That was just a really disrespectful idea to the people we were working with. And we went up to Glasgow
and we worked with this group of recovering addicts called the Carlton Athletic Club, and they're a group of... It was predominantly guys then, and they have soccer teams, and they're all ex-junkies. But they have these football competitions, and they're five-a-side competitions,
and they kicked our ass. Like, we... The five actors, you know? Yeah. All the young... We got our ass handed to us by all these ex-junkies. But once we started working with those guys, and we had a...
We had this guy, Eamon, who was our advisor on set, and he... He took us to some meetings, and I started listening to all these guys, and, you know, I saw guys who'd been sober a long time, clean a long time, and then some guys who just, you know,
who were still in withdrawal, and I felt like once I met those guys and saw what was going on in their... In their eyes, you know, I thought it would be just massively disrespectful to not have all your faculties together. So it was... It was...
From then on, we just... Yeah, we didn't... What were you and what was the... Yeah, that's not... What was the... What was the feedback from the junkie community? Were they... Was it positive response to the film? Yeah, I...
I'm actually kind of serious. No, no, there was... Yeah, I had both... There was a backlash on the film, because people said it, you know, thought it glorified drug-taking, and I don't think so, and I've never thought so,
but some people did think that, and I met a couple... I remember I was passing a guy, a homeless guy in Soho one night, and he'd seen the movie, and... He was just like... He was like, you're one of us, brother. You know, come...
You've got... He was totally on the wrong side of the fence, you know. He was like, yeah, fucking come on. Oh, dear. Wow. I guess it's better than getting stopped by the gang that loves Star Wars, right? Yeah.
What are you saying? We'll be right back. And now, back to the show. I just finished Obi-Wan, and it's so fucking good. You're so great in it. I love that. How did you get...
How did they get James Earl Jones to come back to do the voice of Vader? I mean, that's crazy. I know. Amazing. I'm just glad they did. It's so amazing. We had such a good time doing it. It was a long time, since we shot episode three.
It was 2003, and... But it felt good, you know. It felt quite good to come. I really... I was in a much better place with it, because our prequels came out, and sort of universally weren't liked by... And it was all pre-social media and everything.
So the sort of voice that we heard were the critics' voices, and they didn't like them much. And so it was pretty disappointing at the time. But the fans liked them, though. Like, that was the thing. I feel like the fans liked them. For the story.
And you're right. Boy, that's an interesting sort of distinction that you've made, that we do live in a time now where the critics' voices have just been completely drowned out, haven't they? Yeah, they're just aggregated now. It's just rotten tomatoes, period. Yeah.
Right. But even that doesn't really matter as much as what social media is saying. And that's not necessarily critics. It's people, right? It's other people. I think so, yeah. Do you...
Yeah, that's interesting. So anyway, it was hard to get back into it, or it was easy or... Well, I think when I finished the third one, I wouldn't have... If you'd asked me then, I'd be like, okay, I was always happy to be in it, and I was very...
I was always grateful to be involved in something that big and to be part of the legend of it, because I loved it. When I was a kid, I loved those films. I mean, I was seven, I think, six or seven when the first one came out. And just like, you can't...
You know, it's in you somehow. And I know it is, because when I was working on this series, and I was faced with Vader for the first time in all his, like, scary majesty, I was totally knocked the wind out of me. It was quite scary seeing him coming at you. And Stormtroopers, like, I never...
I never acted with Stormtroopers on the prequel, so we did scenes with Stormtroopers. And I was like a boy again, you know, just like deep inside me. And talk about a huge difference in... I mean, I know there was a gang of work between, you know, Shallow Grave and Trainspotting, and then the Star Wars work.
There's tons of stuff you did in between there. But, I mean, the difference between probably what? Like a 28-day shoot on those earlier films, and then Star Wars, it'd take you probably a half a year to shoot those movies and working with green screens and all that kind of stuff. I mean, I would imagine your answer to which do you like better.
You'd probably say, you know, little bits of each, but it's a totally different process, isn't it? It's a different process, and it teaches you that you're always challenged, aren't we? But every job we do, there's some challenge that it throws at you. And in those prequels, it was very much the challenge of, like, being...
Trying to be believable with this dialogue in front of a blue curtain, you know, for four months. Hey, is it true that George Lucas didn't give you guys the script until, like, two days before every scene or something like that? Is that true? No. Okay, thanks.
It was one of those, you know, I had to go to the studio and sit in a room, sort of locked in to read it. Oh, I see. But we had the script. You know what made me laugh? It made me laugh so hard. I read somewhere, I saw you in an interview or something, saying you used the force, the Jedi force,
to open automated doors at, like, supermarkets and stuff. But only if people are watching. If I think somebody's watching... I give it a little... You do a little, like, wave in front of the door. That is so funny. And don't get anything away here, just like... Now, you and you can go around to...
You can go around to stores and supermarkets and movie theaters and stuff like that, or do you get tackled by fans and stuff, or do you just kind of get stopped and say, oh, hey, I really like your stuff, and would you take a picture and you kind of carry on? Yeah. Are they nuts because of all the Star Wars stuff?
Because of everything. Oh, and everything, but it made me laugh. Well, I... Yeah, I think it sounds really interesting. You've got this great level of fame, I think, like this perfect level of fame where you can... Your celebrity can get films financed and be a recruiting element for other cast elements
and directors and stuff like that. You can still go out and have a... Yeah. You maybe could find some anonymity if you just kind of dress right, you know, you can... Yeah, I don't... I just tried to just do it, to do my life and not... Yeah, yeah.
To a point. And then there's a point. It's always... It's unavoidable when you're somewhere... You know, when you go to do press somewhere and they know the hotel you're staying in, and that's unavoidable. And I guess that...
I have to learn to be better with that. Right. I'm not great with the autograph hunters who stand outside your hotel because I... I don't really believe they're... They're just trying to make money. They don't really want the autograph. They want to sell the autographs.
Right. And I find that gets my eye are up a bit, but... Yeah. Now, wait, Jason... Can I just jump in and say my son, Abel, who's 11 years old, and I've never done this, but I'm going to put you on the spot, you and... He asked me to ask you.
He was wondering, why did you accept the role of Obi-Wan Kenobi? Like, was there a reason besides the money? Yeah. That's amazing, Abel. Abel just texted me. Yeah. He just texted me.
He texted you. Brilliant. That's hysterical. He asked me because he knew that you were on the show today and he is... He is... Again, he is such a massive fan, Abel. He is freaking out that you're here today.
And he went... He left yesterday to go up and spend a couple days with his mom and he is like freaking out. He knew you were coming on today and then he just texted me that knowing that you're on now. That's cute. Well, I imagine you didn't probably
even need to read the script, right? I mean, the yes was probably automatic, given... No, I really had to think about it because it came quite shortly after that trans-spotting period and really, by that time, I was so full of myself. You know, I was like this...
I'm Danny Boyle's actor. I'm like fucking urban grunge. Here I go. I am the oasis of the British movie industry, you know? And then when the Star Wars came along, I thought, I don't know if I want to do this. This isn't me, you know? Right.
And also, I worried about sort of... I suppose I was worried about typecasting or something like that or... Because you're going to be so famous from it. It's just going to be so big, I think. Yeah. And then I thought, well, I don't know. It didn't really...
I was so into being the sort of anti-hero, if you like, you know? I live in America now, but for a long time I didn't and I thought, I'm going to do it, you know, like a indie British actor is what I felt like. And I felt, more than anything, I felt like I was Danny Boyle's actor and I felt that that sort of defined me.
I really did. And so I did... I asked everybody, I spoke to them. My uncle was in all three of the original ones. He played Wedge and Tillies, my uncle's an actor called Dennis Lawson. And I asked him and I said, what do you think?
And he said, if you want a career after 30, don't do it. That's what he said. Oh, really? What did Danny Boyle say? Did you ask Danny Boyle? I did ask Danny Boyle, yeah. I think he said that I should do it. But in the end I just got closer and closer.
Like, the closer I got to it, I remember doing, you know, going to recalls and recalls and screen tests and then meeting George and it got down to like two or three of us, I think. And by that time I just thought, I just was so attached to the idea of it from when I was a kid that I thought, you know, to get a chance to be that character
and to be the younger Alec Guinness is pretty awesome. Yeah. But you were also signing up for what, three? Two or three? Three at a minimum? Yeah, three. But the other thing is like you asked your uncle, but the last thing you should do is ask another actor
any advice on whether or not you should do something. I think it's like the worst thing to do because they can't help but put their own fucked up, you know, reasoning into it or their own desire or whatever. They can't help it. I remember one time... They didn't ask me to do it. Yeah, exactly.
They didn't ask me. Right. And I wouldn't do it. I wouldn't do it. I remember years ago, years ago you were at the Golden Globes and I remember because Bradley Cooper at the time was, I think he was on Alias maybe.
And so he was there. He had gone and he was like, I'm going to the Golden Globes tonight. And we lived in the same... And so then he came back and he was like, man, he and I were just talking about this the other day because I told him you're on the show and he goes, man, I just saw Ewan McGregor was there tonight
and he had like eyeliner on. And he was there and he goes, and he would look so fucking cool. And he's like, and we could never pull that off. We could never do that. And he was right. We were like fucking... You had eyeliner on at the globe?
And he was so cool. Ewan was. And we were like, fuck man, we could never do this. I did that film Velvet Goldmine with Todd Haynes. And I just loved it. And I really always had this rock and roll fantasy, you know, that I probably still have a little bit that wouldn't it be amazing to be like a rock and roll
or on tour and stuff. And I don't think that... So for a while I did a war makeup and nail, you know, like nail varnish and stuff, but only for a little while. And I liked it. And I've always liked like, yeah, this isn't probably what you should do.
So I'm going to do it, you know, at the globes. Maybe it's not the best. I know me. By the way, you pulled it off. It was very cool. And I get it too, because you just... I'm also a contrarian, I think, by nature. And I'm always like, if everybody else is doing it,
then that means I absolutely cannot do that thing. Often to my own, you know, disservice or whatever. You know, it's not always the best thing, but I don't know if... I'm sensing that there's a little bit of that in you as well. I know. There's definitely... I'm like that with movies that are hugely successful.
I'm like, well, I'm not going to watch it. You know, and then I see it eight years later and I'm like, that film's really good. It's like, yeah. Right, right. Yeah, that film was really good eight years ago. I know. I do the same thing.
I do that with movies. I do that with TV shows. I was like, hey, man, during the pandemic, I was like, have you guys seen The American Office? It's really good. And I'm friends with a lot of people on the show. I'm friends. Like Krasinski and I had to be like,
I actually never watched it. I'm like, it's really, really good. I did that with Breaking Bad. Breaking Bad, I watched like two years ago. I feel like I'm going to be saying that about the Sopranos when I get that watch. Yeah, I've never seen the Sopranos. I did that.
The Sopranos was my one years later. Years and years later. Did you not watch it? Not yet. It's really good. Like one here or one there? Yeah. You and this is a true story.
One day, when Jason and I were working together years ago, he came after a weekend and he goes, hey, you know, this is a true story. He goes, hey, you know, Blues Brothers is pretty good. And I go, this is like 2004. 2004 and I go, Blues Brothers, the 1978 film? Yeah, it's pretty good. I just figured everyone had sort of missed it.
Like me. Everyone's like me, right? There's so many of us. That's a narcissist, Captain Narcissism in me. That's just terrible. That's terrible. That's funny. Ewan, where did the motorcycle passion come from?
I've always ridden motorbikes since I was, well, no, I wanted to ride motorbikes since I was a teenager and my parents would never let me. And so it was just after I finished drama school, I realized that I could do what I wanted, you know. And so I got my first little motorbike in London. And I used to park outside and when they came to visit me, there was a lovely girl upstairs called Elska.
I used to take all my stuff up to my riding gear, my helmets and gloves and I'd stash them in her place so they wouldn't see them, you know. And pretend that, anyway, that went on for a while. And I started riding, I just love it. I still love it as much as I ever did. And I started, I rode everywhere in London. I'd use it to get about and I'd go for trips on it.
And I met my great mate Charlie Bormann when we made a film together called Serpent's Kiss in Ireland. And we'd both just had babies and we were both into bikes. He'd grew up riding motorbikes. And so we just sort of, we did a lot of track days together and we were involved in a race team, not riding, but we were sort of the sort of glam squad for this little motorcycle racing team.
Like road bikes? Road bikes, yeah, like track racing. Wow. And then I read this book written by Ted Simon who wrote a beautiful book called Jupiter's Travels in the 70s and he was a journalist, I think for the Sunday Times, and he decided he wanted to travel the world
and he wasn't a biker, but he just thought that's the best way to see the world. And he's right, it really is the best way. There's something about it. So he wrote this, he got a triumph and he rode around the world and it took him four and a half years. And his book started, he starts like three and a half years in
and he's run out of petrol and he's sitting underneath a tree in India somewhere and his bike's propped up there because he's got no gas. And he just said, I'm sitting here safe in the knowledge that someone will come and help. And that's sort of how the book starts. And it had taken him three years to realize
that that was a truth, you know. And there's something beautiful about his writing in the book and it's just sort of boiled away in the back of my brain. Until one day I was thinking of, Charlie and I were always talking about looking for somewhere to ride and we thought we'd go to Spain from London
on some sports tours and we'd take our wives on the back and then maybe they could fly home and we'll race back. And I just started thinking, well, I don't know, and then I would start looking further afield and I got a world map and I looked at, I thought we could go to China and back.
That would be cool. And then I thought, well, what would just come back along the same route? And so I kept looking right on the map and it was sort of a direct line around to America and, you know, Canada and I just thought, well, we could do that.
So that was our first trip in 2004. Wait, you went all the way around the world? We went from, well, it's officially not around the world trip because it's only the northern hemisphere, but we rode from London round to New York. So we rode from London. Oh my God.
And we went in the channel tunnel to France and then we rode to far eastern Russia and Siberia. And then we got a plane with the bikes to Anchorage and then we rode from Anchorage to New York. And that was like four and a half months and we shot it. We shot it as a documentary with this amazing journalistic cameraman, Claudio von Planter,
who's our guy and he just rode with us. Big name. So a third bike. That was a three bikes. And then we had a couple of pickup trucks that we saw once in a while and we'd, you know, and then we did Africa. We did the whole African continent in 2007
and we did from Terrell Del Fuego, which is the tip of South America to Los Angeles and just before the pandemic in 2019 on electric bikes on the electric. I saw footage of that where you guys were in Chile, I think, going across the flat. In those electric bikes. That's pretty cool.
They're all on Apple. There's three documentaries, Long Way Round, Long Way Down and Long Way Up. That's the order to watch them. Oh my God. That's pretty cool. That's great. I have a question.
Do you... Okay, go ahead, sir. And state your name first. Where are you calling from? But do you and Jason, do you guys ever get mistaken for each other because I always thought you guys kind of look similarly? I've always thought that.
My wife wants us to play brothers forever. Me too. I've always said that. I've always said that. Because you're beautiful, Ewan. You're really, really handsome. What a compliment to Jason, that is. That's an incredible compliment to Jason.
No, I see it. I definitely am, no. Ewan, do you feel like playing his much younger brother? Let's do it. No, I would definitely play his kid brother. Twins. You know, just sort of like, hey... Jay, you could be his dad almost.
I sort of got... Will, can I talk to you for a second? Move your camera a little bit. I think we should put it out there, Jason. It should happen, don't you think? Yes, please. We should do some... I'm ready.
Indie brothers thing. Ewan, how's your American accent? Is it quite good? I think it's okay. Of course it's good. I think it's all right. It's been working this whole life. I've worked with Liz Hemmelstein.
Did anyone work with Liz Hemmelstein? No. Well, you probably don't have to work with someone with your American accents, but I do. Well, I'm Canadian. I had to work with... Will, wait. Did you really work on getting rid of your outs and abouts?
No, I didn't. Out and about? Out and about? No, I did, but there were certain things that I just tried to get rid of. Oh, sure. Then I didn't go up at the end of every sentence. You didn't have to take the question mark off every sentence. Yeah.
I didn't say house. But I used to do... I used to... It's an absolutely brutal day for motor car racing. That's good. I used to do that. Is that Jackie Stewart? Do you do Jackie Stewart?
Yeah, it's Jackie Stewart. It's Jackie Stewart. Jackie Stewart. He's still knocking about. He's still at all the races, Jackie. Is he? He's still around. He seems to be very present.
Now, are you a golf fan? No, I just was interested in your outfit. Your golfing outfit that you were discussing at the beginning with the funny trouser thing at the front. It wasn't bad. How do you... Do you all play golf? Sean does not.
Will and I do. Jason and I do, yeah. You do? Yeah. Do you play any at all? I grew up playing because I was a... Because in Scotland everybody plays. And then I just...
I've done it from time to time. And I can never get over the fact that I'm not as good as I think I am. So... You always end up in horrible mood. Is that just the way it is? That's all of us. But then, you know, Roy McElroy, he says, don't let golf affect your attitude. Let your attitude affect your golf.
Oh. You know? Okay, that's good. Sean. Oh. I think I... I think I'm good at golf if I could just get out of my way. I think I'd probably...
No, you stick to motorcycles and rock and roll. You're a stud. You're a man's man. Will and I, you know, we're just golfers, you know? Yeah, we're delicate golfers. Here, it's different. I feel like it's different. There's a sort of...
I don't know if it's different. I was always struck me as being different here. And Britain, it seems to be a little bit... Feels a bit more elitist and... Here, it's elitist. Here, I feel like everybody plays golf and, you know, golf clubs are... I don't know because the big golf clubs here in LA are so expensive, aren't they? Like, you have to be...
Yeah, it's a real status thing. I'm not proud of it. I just love the game. Yeah, I will say this. I think the thing that I struggle with the most with golf are a lot of the people who do play golf. And I'm sure we're going to get a lot of pushback from people online. From the golfing community.
And now we've enraged the heroin addicts and now the golfing community. And if they ever got together... There should be a golf championship for heroin addicts. And that would be... They just fall asleep as they're putting... It would be amazing. But you do have... It does...
There is that sort of part of golf that does have this very sort of elitist and kind of exclusionary feel and vibe to it and people who are completely out of touch. And so you never want to become that. That's the part that I don't like. Yeah, but I mean it's like... If you're like doing it like who don't, right? No, I know. Of course.
Of course. But you just hope that you don't become that, you know? I think you're right. I think that seems to be like the golf club side of things. Yes. And then... Because the idea of being part of a club lends itself to that anyway, doesn't it? It's something you have to pay into to be feel special at your club.
But the actual game of golf when you're on the beautiful fairway is an amazing game. It's really challenging and no question. I mean, Will, do I grind or what? I mean, I'm out there just trying to really shoot a low number. He's not even really fun to play with anymore. No, not at all. Oh, you're too serious about it? Yeah, way too serious.
Well, yeah, but I'm just... I'm only out there for the challenge of it. And the slowest golfer in California. I'm speeding up. I'm trying to get faster. You are speeding up. You are getting better. If there's someone behind me on the tee waiting, I get so stressed.
Just on his hip. Oh, don't worry. He doesn't get stressed. I tried golfing in Ireland once with my brother. Did you? Yeah, one of my friends, my brother, Kevin, I played golf with him in Ireland and they didn't have carts. So I had to carry our bags everywhere and I said, I'm out.
And then I golfed... Wait, that's when you came out? Oh, oh, you're out of... Sorry. On a golf club in Ireland? Wow. I'm out. Seems like a good start.
Jesus Christ. I just screamed it. I screamed it. So wait, how come we haven't heard of Kevin before? How many siblings do you have, Sean? I signed for Tracy. I signed for Kevin. Mike, who passed away sadly, my sister Tracy and me.
Kevin, you, Tracy. And Dennis. And Dennis. Dennis is no longer with us. No, Mike. No, Mike passed away. Michael. You've been friends with Jeff for a long time, by the way.
This is embarrassing for you. Will, Will, why don't you tell me the name of your brother real quick? Chuck. That's pretty fast. You're getting faster. My other sister is here. She has a Scottish name. Her name is Shanley.
And the other one is Tennis. Tennis. Tennis. Tennis. That's my job. And then I played golf with Jimmy Burroughs, who was on our podcast. Great golfer. And Alan Thicke, who sadly passed away as well.
But that was really fun. That was in Cabos and Lucas. That was, and I did really well. Okay. You and McGregor's with us. And he's joining us from a very handsome kitchen. Where is your house there, Ewan? I'm in my, this is my, I'm down in my little, I'm in my tiny house.
I've got a little tiny house in my, in my garden. Looks handsome. I do, it's just like quiet in here because there's no one in here. So. Are you in California? I'm in California. Yeah. Yeah.
We'll be right back. All right. Back to the show. So you're, you've lived in America for a long time. You're like five years, six years? Yeah. I moved here in 2008. Okay.
And I became an American two years ago. Welcome. Welcome. I love it here. Yeah. Thank you. I just love it. I love living here and I, no intention to not live here.
I just love it. I love it. What was that process like? What did, what did you have to know? You have to know like the, the, the, the, the Star Spangled Banner or basic history or how does that go? It's a bit, well I, I'm a, it's probably a bit like a driving test, you know, when you learn all this stuff and then as soon as you, as soon as they say you can drive
a car, you forget all of it. So it's a lot of American history. How the political system works here, which is difficult for a bridge because it's quite complicated, it seems. And then some of, you've got to know names of like your local. Oh, senators and then congressmen. Yeah. Congress people, senators and stuff like that.
Yeah. They ask you dates and stuff. They ask you dates of like when things were written and what have you. Oh wow. I did it in 2007. I became, I did the same thing and I remember they did the thing you had to, you had to remember which were the original 13 states, et cetera, and all those sort of things. So I studied.
I wanted to be, I wanted to get a hundred percent and the guy, it's really up to the discretion of the person who, who's giving you the, that final interview, right? It was anyway back then. And the guy goes, he starts asking me a couple of questions and then he could see that I knew what I was, I knew what the answers were. He's like, okay, well you got this and he moves on. I was like, no, no, no. You're not moving on.
I studied this. Yeah. Yeah. Right? Yeah. I had the same thing because you have to get 10 questions. No, you have to get six questions right out of 10. Yeah.
And I got, I got six right. Yeah. It's like a hundred, I think there's a hundred potential questions and they ask you 10 and you have to get at least six of them right. And so once you get six of them right, they go, okay, that's it. And I was like, I was like, you, I was like, no, no, what are the other four? I spent a lot of time learning this stuff, you know. Yeah.
Now, you and McGregor, talk to me about your domestic situation there. You got, you got one kid, two kids, one wife, boyfriend. It doesn't matter. This is a real liberal show. I, I'm, I'm recently married. I married this year to my love, Mary Elizabeth Winston. Congratulations. You got married this year?
I got married this year. Nice. I have four, four daughters with my ex-wife, Ev. Yeah. And we, and Mary and I have a one year old son. So I have five children. Oh, that's amazing. Yeah.
Yeah. So I'm really lucky and very much in love and I'm very, very happy and. How old's your son? I'm blessed with all my kids. He's just turned one. Wow. Okay. I have a, I have a two year old.
I have two older boys from my first, and I have a two year old as well. Yeah. How old are your girls? My eldest girl, Clara is 26. Yeah. My 20 year olds, Esther and Jamian and my youngest daughter, Anook is 11. Oh, great. All ages.
Yeah. I just, I love it so much. I love it so much being a dad. I really do. Dad, did you think you were going to love it as much as you did? Or, I mean, I thought, yeah, this is going to be cool. And then I'm, now I'm just like up, just a baby. I mean, I cry watching commercials if there's a little kid in it.
I just love it. I think I do. I think I was totally old. Yeah. I was, I had Clara when I was 24 years old. Yeah. And I was just always, I always knew that I wanted children and I just, and I really, I really love it.
I really do. It really makes me incredibly happy. Now, quick math there. That puts you at 50? 51. 51. When's your birthday? What time are you?
Sorry, I'm asking for a friend. And then I want to know what your rising is. What are you? I'm born on the end of, I was the last day of March, 31st of March, 1971. So I'm in Aries. Aries. Where are you guys at? What, what ages are we here in there?
Oh, I'm just 35, but I think that we should move on. Will doesn't, Will can't play older than 40. I skew 30. I skew late 30s, but, but I, I'm 50. I'm 52. Sean and I are both 52. We're only a couple of weeks apart. I'm 53.
I'm the adult here. Okay. Yeah. Growing up. That's why you're so good at golf because you're just a bit older than us. Yeah. But I just don't hit it as far anymore. Because I've seen, I think everything you've ever done.
By the way, also audition for down with love still. I didn't get that. Oh yeah. And this make-a-wish is going great with you. Great average. But tell me what it's like, cause you, didn't you do, are you in Pinocchio coming out? Are you in it? Yeah.
Or like you, do you voice it or you're in it? I voice it. It's totally stop frame animation. Wow. And that's Guillermo del Toro. Yeah. Yeah. It's embarrassing.
It was, I had an experience. I don't know if you've ever done this. It's sort of an actor's nightmare of being in a situation where you're absolutely unprepared. And that's what happened with this. I went to meet Guillermo and I thought to discuss the role and to discuss what we were going to do with it. And I arrived and I was in a sound studio with in front of a mic with a lectern with the script on there.
And he's behind the glass. And I was going, okay, let's start off with Q1. What? And I hadn't read the script because I just thought we were having a chat. So I was busy and I hadn't read it. And I started trying to do it. I just didn't tell him. And I thought, I'll just, I just have to go.
So I was started. And of course I had an idea of who Jiminy Cricket was, but it didn't seem to be anything like what I was reading on the page. And I didn't know what accent to use or what I, I, I almost was crying. I just got to the point where I wanted to cry, you know, I was so embarrassed. And I just asked him to come in the room after about 20, I did about 25 minutes of this nightmare. So he comes round into the room and I went, look, I was really tearing up. And I went, I have to tell you, I haven't read the script.
I wasn't, I wasn't sent it. I thought we were having a discussion about, and it turned out, thank God I hadn't been sent it, although I didn't know that for absolute sure. But anyway, then we just, he was just great cause he just went, no, what, what are you doing is good. And, and he talked to me for about half an hour and then we just went and we recorded the whole thing. No way.
And then I read it and we went back in. So it's been one of those things, you've probably all done them when you go back several times you go in and out. And, but I think it's going to be really, I love him and I love his take on things. And so to be involved in this is really cool. Yeah. Well, explain the whole, Will wants to do some voiceover work. We're talking through the process of it.
So the crazy story. Did I, I told you guys this story about when I did Ratatouille, right? Did I tell you guys this? I didn't know you were in there. I was in there. Yeah. And Brad Bird directed. So similar thing.
So I get a call. This is crazy that you just told the story. When was that? That was like at least 15 years ago, maybe more. We were doing, we were, we were still doing a rest of development, original, the rest of development at the time. He goes, they sent me the thing and they go, you're going to go up to Disney to record this stuff.
And I'm like, great. Yeah, no problem. I get up there. I guess it sent me materials, but I'm not sure either I didn't see it or ignored it or whatever. And I was not prepared for what I was walking into. Same thing. Walk into a soundstage, into a recording studio at Disney.
He, Brad's there. And he's like, and he's in the booth with me and they bring out all their, he's like, you've seen all the art for your character, Horst, the sous chef. And they go, yeah, of course I've seen the art. And this one's my favorite. Look at that. And I'm looking at it going, absorb everything, absorb everything, you know, just, and I'm looking at it.
And then he goes, so obviously, and as you know, cause Horst is German and I'm like, yeah, right. Cause he's German. And I'm thinking like, what the fuck? And I'm thinking, I don't think I do a German apart from like what you do in a bar to a friend. I don't know. And he goes, and then he's like, okay, let's go.
And I'm like, what the fuck am I going to do? Same thing. The panic, the sweat, the fucking, and he's right there. And Brad Bird, I revere the guy who made the Incredibles. He's a great director. He's got a super sweet guy. And I just did it. I just bullshitted my way through.
I did this fucking, the movie exists to this day. Oh my God. Do it. Do it. Three, two, one. German accent. Three, two, one. I did that.
That's very good. Four, three, two, one. Now you and Jiminy Cricket. Was he, is he Scottish? Yeah. Sort of very like my. Cause I didn't really know what else to do. So I, he's very close to me.
Did you go higher? Did you go higher at all? He's just small. He's tiny. So I like, He's weed. I've always shouting everything because, because everyone's so far away. You know,
It's a very shoooty performance. It's a very shouty performance. But now, Keoh! This summer, in his shoutiest performance to date, Ewan McGregor is... Ewan, I want to hear a little bit of an American accent. Just for a second, just a little bit. I am Jason Bateman.
Yeah. Hey, I'm Jason Bateman. Yeah, that's pretty good. There's so many American accents under. Too manly. It's unbelievable, too manly. Yeah, that was true. Are you excited about something next?
Because you always just pick the coolest stuff, you always work the greatest people. As you like working that much? I tell you what, I've really learned that I like not working, too. Now that we had the experience of being off for that year, you know, with lockdown, and I've never really been that great at not working. I like working and I enjoy it so much, what we do,
but I realized that I was actually much better at not working than I thought I was. So now I've got this little boy and I'm with Mary, and I feel like I just want to, I do want to spend less time away and more time at home. So this year I've done very little, I've done a lot of promotion for the Star Wars show this year, and I don't know exactly what I was supposed to be making.
I had the experience that hasn't happened to me a lot where I was going to be making a movie in Scotland. And so I sort of planned my year about making this movie in Scotland for the whole of the autumn, and it totally just disappeared. I was just texting the director one day about a question about something else, and he went, oh no, we're not doing it.
I was like, oh. Thanks for letting me know. What about Moulin Rouge? Because you were so great in that, would you ever do another musical? Yes, totally. I loved it. And I did a musical on stage after that.
I did Guys and Dolls in London for six months. Oh, that's right. That's right. And I really liked it. It was what an amazing thing to do. It's quite something to get on stage and do something like that every night. A Burroughs, right?
A Burroughs? Did A Burroughs write that? Yeah, A Burroughs wrote that. The guy Jimmy Burroughs we were just talking about was on the show. He's our friend. He's a great television director, one of the greatest. And his dad, A Burroughs, wrote it.
Oh, wow. So when you're not being a great dad and a great husband, to fill your days, what would you do? Aside from being a dad and a husband, do you have any dumbass hobby like me and Will playing golf? I do. I have always loved motorbikes and old car and VWs, like old Beetles and buses and stuff.
So I'm a bit of a... You're out there fixing them up and stuff? Yeah. I like to put potter. I'm not great. I'm not like a mechanic or anything, but I do faff around. I like faffing around in there.
And I spend hours in my shed. Now, what is the goal when you... When I see people working on engines and stuff, it's not just about the difference between making them run and not run. Isn't there like fine tune, like you can make it run a little bit quieter or make it run a little faster?
Like what are you out there? What do you do when you're faffing? He's generally just trying to make them move. So it is about on or off? With the kind of stuff that I like. It's not that fine tuning really. The VWs are pretty simple and I just love them. I love them so much.
How many you got? I have three Beetles and I've got two buses. I've got an old 1960 Rolls-Royce that I love. Did you see the new VW electric car? Yeah. It's pretty cool, huh? I'm actually doing... I'm working with VW now when they promote the new electric bus.
Because I did that big trip on an electric motorbike and I've been an enthusiast of VWs for years. So we got in touch and we've made a couple of commercials with my old stuff and moving into this new electric bus. Don't they own Porsche now? They always have. Yeah, so many. Porsche and Lamborghini and Ducati.
VW owns Audi, Audi and Porsche. I drive the new Audi. Who's got a new Audi? Yeah, I drive the new Audi all-electric vehicle. It is my favorite car of all time. It's less written, Sean. Still roaming less written and... No, it really is my favorite car of all time.
You and what's the ad that you do for the travel company? I love... Hang on, I just have to say... Expedia. A voiceover guy. I love your intonation on... It's not about the things we have. It's about the...
What is it? What's the final line? It's the places we go. Well, are we going to live our lives and regret the things that we didn't buy or the places we didn't go? Or the places we didn't go. And the way you say it... Oh.
I fucking love it, man. It's so good, right? Oh, man. They play it on sports all the time. It's so good. I like that. None of my Hyundai reads... No, Jason, I don't...
Hyundai, you know, it's your journey. You don't like the way I say it's your journey, you know, the way it really hit your, no? You and... When you're on the Expedia, it's so good. Have you heard my lemons? Have you heard my lemons? Yes, lemons.
Lemons. I like the lemons. Lemons. Lemons. Lemons. Yes, you come in on that lemon. I haven't heard that. Lemons.
Lemons. It's very difficult. Is it wrong that I really... I think there was a time back in the train spotting days where I would have been like, fuck that, not doing a fucking advert. And now I'm like, can I do another Expedia? Can we get in touch with Expedia? Nashing his teeth about doing Star Wars.
And now it's just like, we're going through all the... Yeah. Well, this is the best, right? Time's changed. Bring it on. I'm like... It's the absolute best. I love doing it too.
It's so good. And we're available. We're available for limes. So, you and... God, we could talk to you forever. It's so great having you here on the show. I really enjoyed it. That was a very fast hour. Yeah.
Very fast. God, you're a delight. I didn't have been so nervous. I was very nervous before. I don't know why. No, no, no. I guess because I haven't met you all and I was impressed to be on your show. But I've had a great time.
I'd love to meet you in person one day. That would be great, buddy. Yeah. Yeah. I'm going to look for something where we've got... We've got a brother thing going. I think we should definitely do that. I'd love that.
We're going to find something. I'd watch the hell out of that. Let's do it. We'd watch the hell out of it. All right, guys. You and such a pleasure. I love you. I'm such a huge fan.
Thank you for being here. Thank you so much. Well, thanks for having me on. Thanks for doing our show, buddy. Thanks for doing it. Great to meet you. Cheers, guys. All right.
Take care. Bye, Yun. See you. Bye. Bye. Wow. We have had nice people on the show. Yeah.
But really nice people. I feel like he may... That might be the gold right there. As far as just nice, sort of like... Real. There are... I knew, Sean, I've been sitting on this one for a while. And I knew I was like, oh, Sean is going to flip.
Just because he played Obi-Wan Kenobi? No, but then in those movies, but then he just came out with a series of Obi-Wan Kenobi. And also just like, I've seen like train spottings in my all time favorite movies. Like that's one of the movies that made me want to be an actor. Really? Yeah. Wow. I just have just been...
I just always assumed that that's a really good dude. Yeah. And there it is, sure enough. There you go. Yeah. I had heard a couple of people just sort of anecdotally say that he's just the coolest, nicest, realest person. Yeah, I love him.
I know. You know, it's so great. I love his accent is so great. And he's Scottish. And we were talking about the open, which was played in... Up in St. Andrews in Scotland. Not to be confused with the Canadian. There is another St. Andrews, but that's called St. Andrews.
Bye. The sea. Bye. The sea. Really well worked in there, Will. That was good. I've been sitting on that since we talked about... No, it just occurred to me and I was like, wow, how am I going to get there?
Anyway, bye. Bye. Bye. Smart. Last. Smart. Last. Smart.
Last. Smart. Last. Smart. Smart. Less. Smart. Less.
Less. Smart. Less. This is where we'll start. Smart. Less. This is where we'll start. This is where we'll start.
This is where we'll start. We'll start. Smart. Less. Smart. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.